there was a very cookie cutter idea of
precisely what we should look like it
was solely about beauty
and not necessarily about brains Meghan
Markle recalls feeling objectified on
Deal or No Deal during a conversation
with Paris Hilton who says she can
relate after being cast as the dumb
blonde on the simple life The Producers
just said we want Nicole you to be the
Troublemaker in Paris we want you to be
the Rich dumb blonde and
that's you know when I started like
really playing into that character the
dis and the heiress made the revelations
podcasts archetype
she recently stumbled upon the game show
which she was on as a briefcase model in
2006.
this brought back a lot of memories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the former suit star claims that before
tapings of Deal or No Deal the models
would line up at different stations
lashes extensions and bra padding and
they were given spray tan vouchers every
week and when I look back at that time I
will never I'll never forget this one
detail because moments before we'd get
on stage there was a woman who ran the
show and she would be there backstage
and I can still hear her
she couldn't properly pronounce my last
name at the time and I knew who she was
talking to because she would go
Markel suck it in
Marcel suck it in eventually Megan quit
the show I was thankful for the job but
not for how it made me feel which was
not smart and by the way I was
surrounded by smart women on that stage
with me but that wasn't the focus of why
we were there and I would end up leaving
with this pit in my stomach knowing that
I was so much more than what was being
objectified on the stage I didn't like
feeling forced to be all looks and
little substance and that's how it felt
for me at the time being reduced to this
specific archetype number 24.
and Paris she says she knows a thing or
two about that well Nicole and I did
that show there was nothing like it so
we were just we had no idea what we were
getting ourselves into the entrepreneur
has been candid about the trauma she
experienced at boarding school as a teen
it was terrifying I literally thought
that I was being kidnapped because I had
no idea who these people were and
to be taken in the middle of the night
like that
is something that I've had nightmares
about ever since it's
it's hard to really describe how that
feels but it was like something out of
like the movie Taken like it was
it was horrifying Paris explains that
she built her barbie-esque Persona as a
coping mechanism to keep her going in
her darkest moments I started kind of
building this Fantasy Life and this kind
of Barbie doll character
I guess just to not think about the pain
and just to think about oh unicorns and
butterflies and Barbie dolls and pink
and sparkles and I don't know that was
like the only thing that like kept me
going because it was it was uh
miserable after leaving boarding school
Paris and her BFF at the time Nicole
Richie were cast on the simple life
where she says she was pinned as the
Rich dumb blonde Joshua looking good
all right what do you want me to call
you
princess Paris or
I almost got like stuck and lost in the
character where at some points it was
like lines got blurred where I it's like
I forgot who I was and um I don't know
makes me sad because I used to be such a
free spirit and I was just so
like I don't know just like not so
closed off now Paris wants our fans to
know she's anything but the dumb blonde
and she's turning her pain into purpose
advocating Against Child Abuse
particularly at residential schools like
the one she attended the new influencer
is the activist
and I'm seeing a lot of that right now
this new generation really cares about
the planet they care about making a
difference and really fighting for
causes and I find that to be just
so commendable and I really applaud them
and
I don't know I just see this whole shift
right now and it's very impressive
[Music]